thank you Jim and welcome to all of you
and the Maquis no collection arrived at
Columbia in 2007 as you've heard and I
began processing the collection in
mid-september of 2008 with a few months
assistance from the previous star
library archivist Michael O'Connell and
with the help of former Leeds make on
University graduate student and now one
of our panelists today at sequoyah in a
nutshell the collection contains over
14,000 books over 10,000 magazines
almost 2,000 file folders that look like
this sometimes labeled sometimes not not
archival so we have to rehouse them and
other materials sometimes objects
sometimes film but not very much film
and all in all there's 80,000 items
about 14.5 tons over 900 linear feet
yeah it's big and as those as those of
you who are familiar with the collection
are aware it focuses on the print
materials mostly related to Japanese
film that were collected over the course
of 50 years by former filmmaker and film
researcher mr. machina Mamoru in the
1960s and 70s mr Mackey know worked on
documentary films for several film
production companies and beginning in
1960 he started collecting materials for
his research on the proletarian film
League of Japan or pro Kino for short
and that was a left-wing film movement
active in the 1920s and 30s and he also
collected materials related to it from
the Touhou film studio where many
left-wing film writers and directors
worked and he went on from there mr.
machina went on from there to write
about other areas of Japanese film
history and in the process collected a
vast array of additional materials to
assist in his own writing
he later brought into his collection
from purely Japanese sources to include
sources from China and Taiwan and the
former colony of Manchuria and South
Korea an area of which i have yet to
process overall mr. machina recognized
that in in order to construct film
history first it's necessary to collect
documents and in order to collect
documents one must learn the issues that
preoccupy the Pioneer acrylic who
collect the documents or who created the
documents excuse me and so that
philosophy drove his approach to
collecting so today I'm going to just
introduce a few highlights of the
collection and give you a sense of how
processing works to date almost thirty
percent of the boxes in the Maquis no
collection have been have been processed
and can be requested with my help
processing began with the scenarios or
the scripts in the collection followed
by the film production company materials
or studio studio materials then director
files and then pre-war materials more
generally these items are either rare
important to the field of film studies
or ephemera potentially unique to the
Maquis no collection and while working
on these materials I sometimes came
across materials on other subjects in
the same box and so I began processing
those materials too while they were
close at hand so I've either processed
or I'm continuing to process materials
that include among other things
censorship pre-war and wartime film
magazines left-wing literature related
to pro kino and others amateur film
magazines or small gauge film materials
which are in the middle eight millimeter
9.5 and 16 millimeter film called cogito
ergo sum documentary film materials film
festival and exhibition materials and
photo albums among others the collection
contains over 1000 pre-war scenarios
screenplays or scripts you could call
them and refer to in Japanese as cocoon
or
simply she nah do these are valuable
because many are handwritten and in some
cases we have several versions of the
same script so this 14 of the film the
lifted spear or doe COI co NHO yachties
is one of two scenarios for films in the
Maquis no collection that were written
by the well-known director Kurosawa
Aikido the lifted spear was never made
into a film so we have scenarios that
were never made into films and along
with the scenarios there are even
related story boards as you see as you
see in this next slide which depicts a
scenario and a storyboard from a 1960
film there are some notebooks with
related photographs or sketches I put
them together so you could see that they
were toys and so these sketches are for
a sketch on a photograph for the film
journey to the west which is a japanese
translation of a chinese classic it's
undated but it may be for the 1917
version of the film and then here's
another example of a handwritten
storyboard which is kept with the
scenarios but also has a related sketch
that one so mr. machina acquired the
scenarios for about half of the films
for screenwriter and director in away
Quintero who was active in the 1920s and
30s we have 16 boxes archival boxes of
material for just the inna way scenarios
and mr Mackey no also acquired the
scenarios of the screenwriter Ikeda
Tadao who wrote scripts for directors
like oh so yeah tsujido not a semi kyo
and others and we have about 14 archival
boxes for his materials so in addition
to scenarios we have over 3000 leaflets
or handbills or cheetah she and they're
from more than 70 different movie
theaters mostly in Tokyo
but but elsewhere and dating from the
1910s through the 1940s some of these
handles also include used ticket stubs
which you'll see in the top top right of
the slide of this handbill from 1940 and
along with the handles we have some
related scrapbooks as you can see in
this slide for a 1948 film that includes
a film screening scheduled inside that's
the first page of it so these handles
offer insight into what films were
showing and when and where they were
showing some also include summaries of
the films themselves and they are all
delicate but visually interesting
ephemera that we may ultimately consider
for digitization but we're still
investigating digital options for parts
of the collection some of you may be
interested in the valuable documents and
reports relating to major Japanese film
production companies these are mostly
from from touhou or an abbreviation of
touhou haga kabushiki kaisha and it
includes documents from the pcl studio
which is also an abbreviation and jo
studio so PCL and Jo merged in august of
1937 to form touhou so we have materials
from all of those parts of the
production company and to give you an
idea of what has been processed we have
22 archival boxes of touhou materials
about 160 folders so manila folders and
but that's just touhou and then we have
materials from shochiku nakatsu told I
and from independent film studios as
well the collection has the complete
works and personal collections of
various film critics including kishi
matsu iwasaki Ikeda who were both
members of the left-wing film movement
and others as well there are many
scrapbooks containing photocopies of the
critics published articles so that's
what the inside of
one of our scrapbooks created by kishi
matzah well looks like it's one of 29
and while today you may search online
japanese journal indexes for lists of
film writers publications the main
database is currently did not provide
the full text of the articles and
locating libraries and archives with the
underlying journals presents a challenge
so mr Mackey knows collection is useful
not only because it contains many of the
journals where scholarship on film was
published since in the nineteen teens
and 20s but it also contains these
scrapbook compilations of many important
critic writings due to mr Mackey knows
own special interests in documentary
film the collection contains numerous
documentary related materials dating
from 1960 and on from when he or he
started collecting from 1960 on so there
are items related to the works of
documentary filmmaker Khmer Fumio who mr
Mackey know got to know in the 1970s
after he worked for him on the 1969 256
film it's good to live or each day day
yokatta and we have a poster so the
common materials include posters like
this one publicity pamphlets programs
scrapbooks documents and scenarios and
information relating to a retrospective
published published on coming ten years
ago for the Yamagata International
Documentary Film Festival so anything
mr. machina wrote for something that was
published like this would be in the
collection um commies 1939 film fighting
soldiers or topical hate I was banned by
Japanese authorities as a potentially
anti-war film come May was the only
Japanese film director arrested for
violating the peace preservation law of
1925 and he was stripped of his
directors license and the Maquis no
collection contains a post-war scenario
that was printed for fighting soldiers
and we also have part of a carbon copy
of a handwritten cut list for a
different film by commie a Japanese
tragedy or nihon no hijiki which
was censored by occupation authorities
so in addition to materials related to
the film directors like calm a female
there are also photographs and albums in
the collection once we got belonging to
cameramen such as Mickey she ghetto and
kikuchi shoe both of whom worked with
coming so for example the collection
contains prints of photographs taken on
location for the film fighting soldiers
as well as Mickey she get his personal
photo albums these albums include
Mickey's work with the folklorist
yanagita kunio on the 1939 film cecchini
aikido or living by the earth and so we
have a poster for that too no sorry
that's another location shot from
fighting soldiers and Mickey turned his
photos into a book with you Nikita kunio
that was called you ki guni no means oku
and mr Mackey no collected the photos
that were taken in Akita Prefecture for
the book and the film so the photographs
in the collection complement the print
materials perhaps of most interest to
scholars the Maquis no collection also
contains commercial film magazines and
issues of harder to obtain minor film
publications from the 1910s through the
war years mr Mackey no is made has made
available many of these film magazines
in reprint editions for which he has
written the commentary and these include
magazines concerning censorship and also
the proletarian film movement in Japan
and while several libraries now have
reprint editions of these magazines the
monkey no collection has the originals
and our censorship and proletarian
archival materials have been processed
and are located in our off-site facility
so speaking of our off-site facility let
me explain how the items are processed
and where they're located
almost all of the 906 boxes in the
Maquis no collection were originally
sent from Tokyo to our off-site facility
in New Jersey which we call recap so
logistically that means I recall to star
library a few boxes at a time for
sorting and processing and although I
visit recap two or three times a year to
review a large portion of boxes at a
time to help determine which boxes I
should next request to star for most of
the collection I call it to star to
process it and most of it will
eventually be sent back off site in
archival safe boxes with a bar code so
that patrons can recall them for use
here in our Special Collections reading
room during rare book hours for now you
need my assistance to request the
process Dione's and you also need me to
contact or need to contact me to access
the materials that are housed here which
include the scenarios the handles photo
albums western film related materials
and pre-war film magazines in the future
you will be able to request archival
materials without going through me by
using the online finding aid books
except for the rare ones will be
catalogued for the special collections
and the rare of excuse me the rare ones
will be catalogued for the special
collections but the other film related
books will be catalog for the regular
stacks or in off-site storage and they
can be checked out of the library and
recalled like all of the other books in
star library's holdings many of the
pre-war books in the collection dealing
with film film theory and the related
fields may be the only copy in the u.s.
I mentioned the finding aid and it is in
process once it is online the finding
aid will contain descriptions of the
contents and links to all the excel
files which contain detailed information
information about the holdings of the
archive and it will also indicate if the
materials are on site in our special
collections and if you need if you need
something now if you contact me I will
tell you if we've been through it and if
we have the Excel files I will
them with you and then you can request
them that way there is a draft summary
of the arrangement that bob hines times
mentioned and that will become the
finding aid for the basis for the
finding aid and it is on our Makino
collection website so please check
periodically to see if we've posted new
material about about what has been
processed and I'd be happy to talk to
any of you individually about how the
funny 8 is structured although the
monkey no collection is not a collection
of films themselves as opposed to
materials dealing with films with the
assistance of a generous recent gift we
are currently purchasing some films that
may relate to the Maquis no collection
holdings so for these films in the
online catalog record you will see a
note that says Makino mamota collection
related film and if anyone has
recommendations for purchase please
contact our Japanese librarians such a
noguchi or you can contact me as well
emailing or calling me is currently the
best way to see if we've process
materials related to your research
interests as those of you who have
already used the collection no I'm happy
to review with you what we've processed
and I rely on your patience if if we
haven't yet processed materials of great
interest to you you may visit the rare
book room during rare book hours to use
Makino collection archival materials
that are on site but please contact me
in advance in case the neat the items
need to be recalled from off-site and
that takes at least a day as I hope this
brief tour of the machina collection has
shown the collection as thousands of
materials useful for film studies and
historical research and we welcome your
visits in the future if you have any
questions please find me after the
symposium or contact me through email